all right guys
bang bang i've got alex here with me
thank you so much for doing this
yeah thanks for having me awesome uh
let's just start with uh
your background before we get into a
bunch of the uh the stories that you've
uh written about uh where'd you grow up
and kind of what did you do before you
got to forbes
yeah so i'm alex conrad i'm a senior
editor at forbes i've been at forbes
for a long time now especially for media
since 2012
um grew up in new york city um
on the upper west side and uh you know
went to school at harvard up around
boston otherwise i've lived in new york
city
my whole life at first i kind of was
hoping to
follow some sort of indiana jones like
career path
but i realized that that was not super
practical in the 21st century
so um well i did kind of study
more that kind of coursework in college
and i'm passionate about
archaeology and history
i realized that storytelling was kind of
the only skill from that
that would would meet kind of a two
requirements it would keep me fed
and you know with a house but it would
also
um allow me to just go deep on a ton of
different subjects and i think for me
that's
that's kind of the way i'm wired is i
love to just you know learn
a ton of different things every day i'm
sure you get to experience that a lot
you know in your job too so um
gravitated to
journalism as a way to tell stories and
get paid to do so
and at fortune magazine as an intern in
2010
i basically faced a choice do i want to
do politics or do i want to do business
writing
um i thought the technology and sort of
the business around technology
was just gonna increase in importance
over time
and um i think that was right
i mean 2010 it wasn't that shocking but
um
you know there were a lot of exciting
companies popping up both in new york
but just
you know everywhere so um just really
leaned into the tech writing
back then um started covering a lot of
the startups that were sort of
you know popping up in the new york
scene locally because most tech writers
were out
around san francisco and the rest is
history i've kind of just
grown with that beat over time it's been
10 years but it's been a lot of fun
yeah well so when you say you want to
follow the indiana jones path
what exactly and most people in college
uh probably don't have like a grand plan
but like what was the general idea was
to go be an archaeologist or something
else
yeah i think the idea was i wanted um
discovery
and i wanted to be sort of sharing the
story of like old
forgotten civilizations and places uh
you know with the world
and so i studied archaeology um dug up
harvard yard
which was really fun we found like an
old building from the 17th century you
know where just the foundations were
underground and the tourists were like
who are these people like why are there
shovels that it was really fun
um and then i was also um you know i
studied some arabic for a couple years
wasn't that great at it but um that was
really interesting
latin medieval history and i kind of
just envisioned you know in some world i
would be like
in sicily or in egypt or somewhere you
know just like
finding forgotten things and then you
know
writing about them and sharing them with
the world that's awesome
i uh i can only imagine the approval
process it went through to get
uh hey we're just gonna like dig up the
earth right no
no problem um so you get to forbes
and uh talk a little bit about what
you're doing now
on a day-to-day basis because you've got
kind of some of the major lists that you
work on but you also write
stories on a pretty consistent basis so
how do you think about your
day-to-day job totally um so i'm a
senior editor
one of the more senior tech folks at
forbes
and so what that means is i kind of have
a balance of
anchor lists that i oversee as well as
um
a lot of our but not all of our tech
coverage um
my specialty is more kind of um venture
capital
and then more of the b2b world where it
comes from startups all the way to the
big companies like microsoft and
salesforce um
you know i've written cover stories on
satya and mark benioff over the years
but then also you know a lot of small
companies i read about too
in terms of the lists um i run the midas
list
which is the uh sort of most visible
um ranking of the world's venture
capitalists by the returns
um i also have co-led our vc 30 under 30
list for a long time
and then in 2016 i created the
cloud 100 list of the top private cloud
companies in the world
um with our partner bessemer and that's
really grown
over the past few years it's gonna be
coming out in a few days
awesome uh let's start with the midas
list uh it is one of these lists that
um it almost feels like the higher up
somebody is the less they care about it
and uh the people who are on the bubble
right
the people who might get into it or or
just barely got into it
uh they really care a lot and so it it
always provides a uh
a couple of weeks of fodder on twitter
where everyone is uh
debating who got what is that you know
legitimate or or not
how do you think of uh the midas list
and kind of the
the purpose behind it and then maybe
talk a little bit about the process you
guys go through and actually determining
uh who makes the list who doesn't make
the list and kind of where they rank
well first you know there's definitely
something with lists where i think you
know the ultimate mic drop move is when
someone wins an oscar or something and
they don't show up
and so i do think that um there's part
of that dynamic where if you make the
list
it might be considered cool to kind of
downplay that
but definitely privately we get a ton of
feedback
we get a ton of feedback from the people
who don't make the list um
privately so it is it is one where i
know the whole industry is watching
really closely and we feel a lot of
responsibility because of that too you
know we really wanted to be as accurate
as possible
um in terms of kind of the process um
you know the list is a data driven list
um
and i'd say the one of the big
complications is we follow it by
individual not by firm
a lot of vcs will say that that is a
team sport which is totally fair
but when you know if mike trout ever
leaves the angels his numbers will
follow him
and it's not like you know the angels
can just write him
out of their history and so i think like
in vc there is a bit of a tendency to
um for firms to kind of trade off of the
big companies like an uber
forever even if the people who did that
deal have left
and so we do follow it by individual the
best we can
um and we also are looking at um
exits or highly valued companies
of the previous five years so private
companies don't count as much as a
public company because
they aren't liquid but we're looking at
basically companies that have raised an
up round or
gone public or been acquired over the
previous five years that way
we don't get you know long time retired
folks
but at the same time it's not a
popularity contest of like which
vc is meaning the hardest that year
absolutely what's the craziest thing
don't name it any names but what is the
craziest thing somebody has
said uh who didn't make the list in
private
like are we talking like anger are we
talking about like uh
um kind of uh posturing and and um
almost like uh trying to position
themselves to win in the next year like
what are those responses like i think i
think the the most brazen
is a correction request where it's like
we've made a formal
factual error and you know their pr firm
is like
you forgot so and so um please update
the list to reflect their name and it's
like that's not really how it works
um but we also get folks who um
will dm me or email me and be like hey
just had this exit
probably not good enough to ever make
your midas list where that salt is
definitely
um apparent you know it's really not
personal and i do feel bad when these
you know feelings are hurt to a degree
um
hopefully they give me good stories
because they're trying to get noticed
more so you're saying like in between
the list coming out people will
literally send you the deals that they
do
so they just to double check that you
for sure know that the deal happened
this morning i woke up to an email from
an unnamed vc
of an exit for a company saying if this
doesn't put me on the midas list i might
as well just give up so
[Laughter]
look and to be honest like there should
be an entire
list you should rank all of the uh
responses you get through the year right
and like almost like strip out the names
and just say hey here was the best
things that i got from people who didn't
make the list because i'm sure that
there's some absurd stuff on there
yeah i would say it's almost worse with
the 30 under 30 list
because um 20 something hustlers
are possibly even more shameless i mean
it definitely is always interesting to
see really successful
heavy hitters in the vc world kind of
taking things personally but at the same
time
um you know it's also kind of flattering
so so we don't want to like punch down
too much
i'd say with 30 under 30 um
unfortunately people
really get the wrong impression that
kind of the more annoying or omnipresent
they are
the better they'll do so so you know
we'll get instagram dms and stuff like
that
and and it's like you know like anything
in life why would
why would seeming um like you're a
stalker be a good thing
i love that and talk a little bit about
uh so the 34 or 30 under 30.
talk a little bit about the process
there because that seems to be a little
less data-driven just given the fact
that there's kind of not as much
quantitative data to actually analyze
yeah so um you know we are
taking nominations right now in the fall
um
and we're especially looking to have
like a more inclusive diverse list
um unfortunately anything where people
are nominating themselves or their
friends it can end up a bit of a
popularity contest
and you know we don't love to see the
same faces over and over
so um that is something that we are
working on
intentionally um that list is nomination
based
so people either raise their hand or
they raise someone else's hand
for them um we also do our own outreach
and then there are industry judges so
unlike some other places
um we actually don't us we don't
like claim to be the experts we actually
just try to find
experts in the domain so like in venture
capital my world
we've had past judges like sam altman
naval ravicon
rebecca kaden sarah taval alexis ohanian
arlen hamilton a lot of big names every
year we have three or four of those
folks
who are actually evaluating the people
my job is to make a baseball card
of each credible person hype them as
much as i can to the judges
and then see what the judges think
awesome and so
obviously you're managing these lists
and kind of working through all the
nuances there and those are coming out
uh on a periodic basis but at the same
time you've got what i'll call kind of
your day job right
or what at least before the list you
were doing which is writing
i mean you do a fantastic job of that
talk a little bit about the recent story
uh
on dustin moskovitz right so um you know
facebook
co-founder kind of you know forgotten a
little bit it seems like and then now
comes
uh back with this company that is um you
know multi-billion dollar business and
seems to uh
really take in the world by storm but
talk a little bit about like why write
this story
and then kind of what that process
looked like totally so
um i first met asana in 2015.
um i think they they were always able to
kind of get in front of reporters
um throughout their history to some
degree because dustin moskovitz
co-founded facebook
for a while he was the youngest
self-made billionaire in the world
that obviously is going to have some
cachet um justin rosenstein his
co-founder was also one of the
sort of key early folks at google
and then facebook as well so they had
that kind of pedigree and they were on
the radar
but asana itself as kind of a work
software team management
company um wasn't the buzziest
over the years and i think you know what
i found out is that a lot of that was
somewhat intentional this year
with covid um it's it works software is
just so important i think you know when
you can't
go just walk into someone's office or
just like shout across the hallway
um you have to be more intentional about
how you work and so
we felt like these tools were very
important in this moment
and then we also knew that asana was
likely going to go public
this fall and so um given that
every year for the cloud 100 we'd like
to profile a really interesting company
that's doing well on the list it felt
like now or never
with asana and so i you know used
that multi-year relationship with dustin
and the team there to try to find a way
that they could talk to us
um you know even given the the ipo
constraints
um so that we could tell the story and
the issue this year
got it and as you're doing this like
what were some of the biggest surprises
to you you'd already known the company
obviously since 2015 but any surprises
that you kind of went really deep to
write the story
yeah so um for for the audience who who
may have read the lean startup
um it's always a pleasure to chat with
eric ries um
who's doing that and long-term stock
exchange and a bunch of interesting
things
and eric is an old friend of dustin's um
so one of the interesting takeaways i
got from from calling eric
was that basically there was a lot of
pressure and not
super high expectations among the the
sort of
technorati of um 2008 2009
when dustin and jr left facebook to
build asana
um you know peter thiel sean parker mark
zuckerberg
matt kohler all those kind of bigwigs
who had made money off of facebook or it
seemed like they were going to because
facebook hadn't gone public yet
they all put money into asana but eric
told me
that they didn't really see work
software
as like a huge opportunity especially
not compared to a social network and you
know
10 years ago social networks were
one of the big things that you could
look at right twitter was still on the
up
you know there was a lot of excitement
there and so eric told me that a lot of
these
kind of you know very famous influential
people
thought oh they'll work on asana for a
couple years and they'll probably go
move on to something that's a bigger
idea
so i think it was really interesting to
kind of see now in hindsight how they
persevered there
um with the huge expectations of having
come from facebook
but without that buzz of you know a
facebook or a tick tock or something
like that
so that would be probably the first one
and then i'd point to one
other which is um you know he said that
the hot companies this is dustin
um as they were building were kind of
like palantir
dropbox um companies like that at least
in his world
they were all bragging about how fast
they were hiring
they were bragging about big customer
wins it was kind of like
philip you know part of that
supercharged culture and it's
at asano they just took a very different
approach where they had um they took a
week off every
quarter to um talk about what went well
and kind of map the next
quarter um which is a long time to take
as a startup
um i'm sure you're you know you probably
have a lot of guests who would be like
that's crazy and
um they also had like no meetings on
wednesdays just banned
from having meetings they just wanted
people to be in flow state
they brought in executive coaching
really fast um
so all this kind of mindfulness and then
they also practice what they preach by
saying we're not gonna we're not gonna
more than double head count in every
any one year period so so they kind of
like
deliberately put these guard rails on
how fast they would grow
to try to be that kind of like
sustainable company
um that maybe seems a little cooler now
but especially i think like a few years
ago that was not the uber approach
it was not the approach that was being
hyped and so
i found that kind of interesting to see
it paying off today
yeah and it feels also like um it's just
proof point that you can build
these enterprise cloud companies in a
whole bunch of different ways like
there's no one
you know one size fits all in terms of
you have to build it this way or it's
not going to work
do you feel like that mentality is
changing like obviously there's uh this
this deep profile that you wrote
as they kind of look to go into the
public markets and things like that do
you feel like
uh the um they're more open now and kind
of
uh they almost are being forced to be
more public about what they're doing
i think um part of that is dustin
growing as a leader you know that i
think he's more comfortable
um you know people can follow him on
twitter he shares a lot of points of
view
and i think you know he has evolved he
calls himself an introvert and he talks
about having an extrovert budget
of kind of like you know public facing
things that he'll do um
including an interview with a place like
forbes and um
i think his managing that budget um
has helped them be out there but i also
think as you're saying
it's this is the space that matters a
lot
to to not just tech people but anyone
who's trying to like work in a knowledge
worker role right now and so if they're
not
out there talking um when would they be
like this is their moment
you know and so i think they have to be
out there but it's not just asana um
another company that does well on our
list is monday.com
they um are like you know
audience members may know them from
their youtube ads like i feel like every
other youtube video i watch there's a
monday ad
so they've taken like a very consumer
approach to getting their word out there
um and there are a bunch of these
companies doing well notion
airtable um so i think we're seeing this
exciting moment
for like workflow companies
and if you want to be in that game you
got to be out there
yeah that makes sense you you also wrote
uh a story about
um another guy who uh i think is very
well respected in the circles that he
operates in but is uh not well known to
kind of the average person which is lee
fixel
uh talk a little bit about um you know
the
the
uh business that he built before he left
to go on his own and kind of
uh what that process of writing uh that
story was like
yeah so writing about lee was tough
because he keeps
a really low profile um i think um
uh your your partner paulina um
was like i finally got him to talk sort
of like which was
which was a fair way to put it um you
know
we did really well at tiger global
they're one of the big kind of growth
investors
out there especially in the tech space
um uh
and and lee is one of a couple kind of
people who were really successful there
they started pretty young
under chase coleman and then they became
these kind of titans of finance it's
it's lee and scott schweifer being the
the sort of two biggest ones perennial
midas list members
and um lee uh last year basically was
like
i want to do my own thing um this is you
know this is my understanding from
conversations with a ton of people in
this world of course
um i don't want to make it seem like i'm
directly quoting him on a lot of stuff
but basically um you can be
super successful be in a ton of cold
startups like peloton
uh many others glossier at tiger
but you can't run your own shop it's
like a more traditional financial firm
and so lee has started his own fund
edition
um billion plus funds where he can kind
of
groom the next generation and be doing
his own thing investing in startups
um with like total flexibility uh what
stage
the coolest thing about that was i spoke
to a ton of his entrepreneurs for the
story and they had some really good
good stories like john foley the ceo of
peloton
um told me that he only the only stock
he owns is peloton
but if he were to venture out from from
that
he would give money to lee to invest on
his behalf
and that there was actually a boardroom
push um to get rid of john
you know when peloton was not a sure
thing and lee defended him and kind of
thwarted the coup
so stories like that are just
fascinating to hear and so with someone
like lee who gave us a statement
who i've known just from midas for a
long time but didn't give me a long
on-record interview
the fun thing is to just talk to like
everybody you can find in their life to
kind of get those anecdotes
and why do you think he's been so much
more successful than most
is it something in terms of the way he
thinks about the market does he have you
know
the the ever elusive uh kind of
proprietary deal flow like what is it
that makes him special
i think you know one thing is that lee
is definitely not an ego driven
investor he's not on twitter he doesn't
want a public profile
and i think that allows him to basically
avoid getting swept up in any trends or
hype cycles
and i think that that helps him just be
a sort of
um dispassionate investor like i'm i'm a
bad poker player because while i think
i'm
i have decent instincts eventually my
emotions get the better of me
and i do something that's you know
messes me up
and i think like to be able to just kind
of keep that flat line
heart rate as an investor is a skill
that lee is probably the best at and
then i would also say he's just really
good at spotting
market trends um obviously there are a
million people at hedge funds and
everywhere who are like
reading reports all day trying to like
see where the puck is going
i think lee just has really good um
decisiveness where he can see a couple
trends and say okay peloton
you know like like he was actually on
vacation reading about different
exercise trends and options and saw
peloton
and at the time it was a deal that like
was very hard for them to do
because the numbers weren't great but he
was just like i really think this is you
know the rising tide that i want to back
and i'm gonna stick my neck out with my
own firm
to commit to it so i think like any of
us in hindsight can be like oh well i
could have seen peloton
but to actually just like put your chips
on the table there
quietly is is what makes lee so good
yeah
and and the other piece is the billion
plus dollar fund that he has i think is
uh split like a third of it's gonna go
to early stage if i remember correctly
and two thirds into growth
yeah are is that a trend that you're
seeing where more and more investors are
kind of blending
uh the early stage in late stage
investing into single funds or is that
something specific to his strategy
it's something that's hard to do when
your firm gets too big
so a firm like andreessen horowitz will
have a crypto fund it'll have a growth
fund it'll have you know an early stage
fund
because um if you have a lot of people
whose careers are depending on success i
think you know
when you get too blended it can be hard
to kind of extricate
one person's success from another or the
fun performance
so if a growth deal is not going to have
the same multiple
as a successful early stage investment
how do you
kind of adequately reward someone for
for a great growth investment versus a
great early stage investment
so i think there are sort of structural
challenges that big firms eventually
face there
you know look at a lot of the best firms
and they are split someone like lee
can move faster because it's just him at
the top
and it's just him deciding what is a
success
and how people you know should be
rewarded so i think that's where the
flexibility
is really attractive to him i would say
i think like lps
like universities or you know the big
foundations of the world who give money
to these species
they probably see him more as a growth
investor but he would say that some of
his
early stage wins um were actually
as good and so to not let him do
that kind of series a check or whatever
is just leaving money on the table
and i just think that being a small
especially being a one man
or one woman band right now um you you
get to
make that kind of choice yeah absolutely
another company uh that i think is
again known maybe to consumers but uh
to the average um kind of person just
paying attention to tech
didn't know two years ago and now is
seems to be everywhere is canva
uh and this story is fascinating to me
because they're not based in the u.s
took a very different approach to
building that business uh but now a
multi-billion dollar company
when did you first meet them and kind of
what was maybe even your first reaction
when you came across uh you know the
approach they were taking the location
they were
uh based in etc yeah so um
melanie perkins the head of canva is one
of the most um
inspiring or impressive you know
entrepreneurs i've ever met
um but when i first met her i um
probably didn't take her as seriously as
i should have
i was at the cloud 100 dinner that we do
most years this year we're doing a live
event for anyone to join because we
can't do a dinner
but um she just made the rising stars
list of companies that
have raised under 25 million but we
think are kind of like on a trajectory
to make the cloud 100 in the future and
um
she came all the way from australia to
san francisco for the dinner
and i just kind of met her you know
casually and was like oh you know design
software that sounds interesting
she seemed like to have a lot of
charisma but
i didn't have any sense of kind of the
community and the numbers
that they were calling um
then i watched as they became a unicorn
they hit a multi-billion
valuation a 2.7 billion evaluation when
i was you know talking to them
and i was like okay what what is the
back story
to this company that is not getting
taken seriously enough because it's
based in australia
so i actually flew down to sydney um
last june
and i spent a lot of time with her and
her partner and co-founder cliff
to kind of just try to like understand
what they had nailed so much
um to build a community of mostly like
very small businesses
because as i'm sure you know well you
can have a ton of small business
customers
and you may not get the scale of like
one of these enterprise companies that
only has a few dozen but they're
they're huge um canva is both it has a
ton of revenue
and a ton of um scale while also like
living off of these mom and pop and
small type businesses
so we went there um fascinating time for
me
um and i i did have a few kind of
learnings from that that i'm happy to
share
um but i would say overall you know the
the the number one lesson was you can
build a business like that
anywhere with the right ingredients and
so i think being in australia they just
crept up on a lot of people
yeah what were some of the other lessons
yeah i would say
um you know canva uh spent a lot of time
uh really like making sure that
its customers were um ambassadors of the
product
so they um they wanted to make sure that
anyone could get up and running
in less than 10 minutes and they would
actually track how long it would take
someone to actually make a design
on canva and i think that's an
interesting thing to keep in mind is
like
how quickly can someone actually take
the plunge to use your tool
so they did a lot of work there um and
then they also did a lot of work
basically paying it forward
with their business where they um
gave away a ton of their features for
free and they really
didn't stress about revenue early on um
obviously
they they had to stay very lean to do
that and i think being in australia
their costs were lower
but they they basically um nailed this
kind of
freemium model um in in a better than
usual way
um so that then when they turned on
their enterprise products you know
businesses
started to convert um and then i would
say they also nailed
um the visual trend right like instagram
and and the power of um
strong visuals and video as part of our
brand today whether it's a person
or a company like that was something
that i think
five six years ago still wasn't quite as
obvious to businesses
especially and so um they enabled people
to basically start
bikini companies by um just having like
great designs to show off their products
i actually met
an australian bikini company through the
process
but they but they they basically saw
that in the instagram world
brands that did not stick out um
in more than just kind of their text or
their products would not get noticed
and and they were like how can we build
tools um
for those folks and so i think like they
they would tell you that social media
was not the original
end-all be-all for them and especially
not instagram but they just
really quickly leaned into that i don't
know how tick-tock
plays into that in the future but i'm
sure they're thinking about it
yeah it just seems like that's a company
uh where it's very obvious uh
the founders understood hey if we can
solve problems for the consumer
uh they'll eventually become our
customer right and it just seemed like
you know reading through that you're
like
every step of the way they kept that
focus um
i i recently wrote a piece basically
talking about uh
this idea of most of the tech companies
seem to have been
customer consumer focused uh for a while
now and that's
playing out now and being a huge
tailwind during covid
a lot of the legacy kind of non-tech
companies whether it's airlines you know
fast food chains etc
i think they always talked about it but
now they're realizing like oh maybe
you know airlines shouldn't charge 200
to let you change your flight right
maybe actually we should just let you do
that because that's a
something that reduces friction and will
lead to you increasing the number of
fights you book rather than decreasing
it
and so it just feels like campbell's
like the perfect embodiment of that
where they just
you know paid attention to what their
customers wanted and have been able to
uh
to grow obviously incredibly fast that's
a great point um i
i think if you're a business where um
talking to your customers is fun
that's a huge advantage right if it's
not fun
that changes the game completely if it's
like how do we minimize
our engagement with you so that you
don't cancel a company like canva i
think they just really
enjoyed like being out in the community
and
talking to their customers and i think
um especially someone like melanie
when when her users felt like they knew
her
or that you know she was one of them it
created a brand loyalty
that is powerful because adobe does you
know it does have a good leader
in its kind of competitive unit in scott
belski
um and and it has good products and you
know design software will not be the
most defensible tool
from a moat standpoint forever but
canvas brand
is extremely strong because i think you
know they actually just love
working with people and so if you you
know wrote them and this is actually the
same as eric yuan at zoom
if if you wrote these entrepreneurs and
were like here all my problems with your
product
they're the kind of founder who wouldn't
get upset they'd be like thank you so
much
i will take all this to heart you know
i'm so grateful that you would reach out
and
that's definitely a mindset thing
absolutely let's talk about zoom
you uh you wrote the perfectly timed uh
profile there
um and they obviously have become the
darling of of this entire
uh pandemic what was kind of your
experience writing that one
yeah eric is one of the just nicest
people
you'll meet um he you know i should
frame
a couple of the emails that he's just
sent me um whether it was like fact
checking
or just feedback um because you can just
see how genuine he is
even now valued at it depends on the
stock but like somewhere around 20
billion dollars or something is his net
worth
but i guarantee you that that would not
come across
you know meeting the guy um he is a real
kind of
just builder um
creator where like all he wants is his
software to be used by as many people as
possible so that he can feel like he's
helpful
like he just wants to be useful to the
world and that really comes off in
everything
um with that company i would say um even
you know when they've had challenges
his genuine self has kind of
given them some credibility there to
figure things out
but zoom crept up on a lot of people
because it's always been in a crowded
market
video software didn't seem that exciting
um and they just decided to build a tool
that was a little bit
better in as many ways as possible than
what was out there and it turns out
you don't have to have the perfect tool
if it's just the best available
and you keep improving it you know
everyone's going to switch to it right
so i think like zoom was just perfectly
pen you know position for the pandemic
um you know i i feel bad for for folks
who didn't read my story at their ipo
and missed out on all that success i
think the stock is up like 6x
since we wrote our initial story around
their ipo
but it was just perfectly positioned
because um now it has brand loyalty
and it's hard to see them losing out on
features when they can just kind of
quickly improve things um that become a
priority
so like they've been improving a lot of
their consumery
features right now because they just
spent three months focused on security
and i think you know their their
competitive advantage is just uh
they know this space as well or better
than anyone right i mean it's it's now
been tweeted a lot but like
a lot of the top engineers that work for
eric at webex
you know jumped to help start zoom so
just like deep
expertise um when i wrote the story i'm
just gonna share one funny anecdote eric
was going around
with um these little envelopes because
it was the chinese new year
and um they just had a dollar in them
each
but eric um gave one to every employee
he could find like he walked up and down
his building
and every time he was like this is gonna
make you rich like
you know working at zoom finally paid
off like don't spend all this at once
and the employee would open it and
there'd be like a dollar and they'd be
like thank you eric and and
he just laughed every time like he's a
he's a corny dad
with like dad humor but i loved seeing
that too just like
the actual joy he had like mixing it up
with the employees
and i think they all got the joke like
if you're a ceo
who's kind of not a very nice person and
you're going around giving everyone a
one dollar bonus that would probably go
over
very differently i'm literally imagining
the reaction that some people would have
and that would not be good
um how much do you think about uh kind
of the financial performance of the
companies that you're writing about
from the standpoint of you know you
mentioned hey we wrote a piece
and then the zoom stock is basically 6x
since then do you
see that as a good thing a bad thing is
it kind of agnostic to you
like how do you just think of i guess
like market impact of the stories that
you write
yeah i would say um
we're i'm kind of betting reputationally
a bit um
the way that an investor does i
obviously and for those who don't know
like
i can't own individual stocks um as a
reporter
so i don't own any zoom or any of these
companies
um unless it's in like a mutual fund in
my 401 k or something right
um but i don't want to spend a lot of
time
talking about a company being
interesting or doing something well
um if they're not right like it's it's
irresponsible
it makes me look like a chump makes
forbes look silly
so there is some risk reputationally
every time we go deep with a company
um so that said it's very validating
when the companies
end up doing well financially because it
helps me
feel like i wasn't crazy that something
stood out about them
absolutely uh speaking of a company that
is crazy uh in a positive way clubhouse
the uh the sweepstakes as i think you
called it uh
talk a little bit about uh well actually
before we do that uh for those that
don't know clubhouse is
i think they describe it as a drop-in
audio app um that you know it's kind of
like a conference call with an audience
uh to some degree
talk a little bit about the uh the
absolute chaos around their uh their
most recent fundraising round and the
competition there
yeah so i mean clubhouse had the perfect
storm
fundraise because it's an app that vcs
are obsessed with
and as much as vcs should be thinking
about markets that are not themselves
it is really easy to see the the demand
for something
when you are the target customer so you
know if you go into a clubhouse or you
check twitter to see who's talking about
clubhouse it is a very high percentage
of these individual investors angel
investors venture capitalists
and so that always meant that they were
going to have a competitive
fundraise i think it got even more
competitive
because of kobit and the fact that
basically
people had nothing to do they were
desperate for a new platform
um and you know tick tock was not really
like an easy investment opportunity it's
such a big company
with bike dance so i think there was a
lot of um
there's a lot of fire power waiting to
back
a company like this the founders also
had credentials having built social
media companies before
it was kind of just like it checked
every box so
there was a bidding war and you know we
were hearing that individuals
were trying to put together angelus
syndicates to give them like a valuation
closer to 200 million
for a company still in beta with under 2
000 users totally crazy
um andrews and horowitz gave them a
valuation around 100 million
um they did did not confirm this to us
but we we talked to enough folks that we
were able to break that story um
and then of course i hear that um
they're in clubhouse like that night
like you know basically like
questioning the reporting or like you
know saying well that's not the full
story and i i was frustrated because i
was like well you can tell me the full
story if you want
but um yeah it was it was just it was it
feels like a million years ago
but it was just a few months ago that
sort of early in quarantine
that app had just kind of struck a nerve
with with a certain part of the tech
world
it's so funny too because a lot of these
consumer
apps uh they naturally want early
you know adopters and kind of beta
testers and so who better than to go get
people who understand how to build
products and you know kind of do all
that stuff which
many of them now invest and so you go
and you get those people on
but uh i always joke with friends like
you get on one of these things and if
you're one of the first
you know 500 or a thousand users on it
it's pretty much always investors
and you see the same investors right and
it's like oh they're so and so they're
so and so
okay i got it like the word is out that
this thing is
uh is being tested that doesn't
necessarily mean that all of them become
like these hot fundraising rounds
uh to your point but but i do think that
it's uh it's this balance between
um you know a canva that says hey look
we're gonna go after small businesses
and kind of as far away from silicon
valley that user base is possible
whereas a lot of these consumer
applications that is who the initial
user base is
it just ends up being uh the people who
know how to build products and
you know people will debate whether
that's good or bad but it's just an
interesting trend they'll see
yeah i think clubhouse is an interesting
test case where basically
they have tried to game
the the sort of consumer um
success trajectory in a bunch of ways
and if it pays off if it works
we'll see more copycats but it may not
work and one of the things they've tried
is
have oprah have these big name folks on
really early on
keep it small so that you can tinker
with a product with a small team
getting feedback from these influencer
types but like basically
only having the influencers on there
right and that's very different from
apps where it starts out with a bunch of
like teenagers or whatever and then
you're trying to bring on an influencer
later on to kind of like confirm
that energy so i think clubhouse like
has gone influencer first
and um i don't think it's guaranteed
that that'll work
um and i do think that of course like
you know communities built around um
groups that are not
obvious could be much more passionate
it's just harder for
for those of us on twitter or whatever
to find them because we may not be in
that community
yeah absolutely uh masayoshi
uh you uh you got the uh the exclusive
interview
i remember polina telling me at one
point she was like this has got to be
the number one interview that everyone
wants
uh one how did you get them to agree to
do it and then two
tell us everything about that uh that
piece yeah so talking to masa yoshi-san
was like top of my list
for probably three years um ever since
the vision fund
burst on to the tech scene um and you
know for those who aren't super familiar
like 100 billion dollar fund to invest
in tech companies it was that's at a
factor
bigger than we'd ever seen before some
of the biggest vc firms in the world
you know their aum is maybe 10 billion
now um
but so 100 billion dollar fund just to
invest in these companies
it was just a massive impact right and
and we were talking about it the whole
tech world
reporting world we're talking about the
impact of this fund for good and bad
um but talking to masa who's based in
japan and doesn't do a lot of interviews
was really hard
i basically found out that he gave maybe
one english language interview a year
and so i just had to like be that
interview
at some point and and i tried you know
multiple times and failed
um but around the end of last year the
beginning of 2020 there were a lot of
doubts around softbank and the vision
fund
wework had obviously been a massive blow
up
and uber um its stock was not doing
great its shares were underwater for
from a sophomore standpoint
there was a lot of doubt so basically
what i did is i said
you know i am not going to be beholden
to any narrative
i am going to hear you guys out and if
there's a way
that softbank can still win here or that
moss is misunderstood
i i will like take that beginner's mind
and i will hear it out and i will try to
give you guys a fair shake
and i think my track record and
i guess my sales pitch were strong
enough
that they thought okay like we will try
that and but i think it was definitely
nervy on both sides um
and i did meet with masa in march right
before everything shut down
in new york it was really interesting
experience and interview
and he was much more unrepentant than i
thought he would be
you know i had a bunch of questions like
what have you learned from this
or what would you do differently and for
someone like him
the answer was kind of like my tactics
might have been wrong but my strategy is
always right
and it's like that is you know that's
what's made him so successful
but it also is why i think the
criticisms can be fair too
so that was it was a trip um talking to
all the people in the south bank orbit
was a unique experience it was extremely
stressful
but we were really happy you know with
the story that we were able to put
together and i hope that
anyone in the audience who goes and
reads that story would think it's fair
look at kind of
why they're in in tough straights but
also how masa can sort of
always you know pull himself out of the
fire in the end
yeah when you met with them in person
was there any other takeaways that you
had
uh in terms of you know it takes a
special guy to uh on the way to pitch
somebody for a hundred billion dollars
to literally
say i think the story is uh they were on
the plane and somebody showed them the
deck and it said a 30-year plan and he
said add a zero
right to it to make it a 300-year plan
yeah so anyone who just thinks
that way is obviously very different but
what were some of the takeaways from uh
from meeting
a person getting talked to well first
off masa is is a lot less
um imperial than i think
he comes off as part of that is because
he has an entourage he's based in japan
it's you go through so many hoops to
meet him you've kind of built him up
in your head but he's actually you know
a relatively
you know small smiling you know
unthreatening
seeming man physically you know just in
like his uh you know
sweater and everything um and and he
kind of walks
serenely surrounded by this
constellation of like freaked out
intense people so that's kind of that
was my first impression is just that
everywhere he went it seemed like
he was totally calm and this is someone
that if you sat next to him at a
you know ramen place you could have a
beer with him but
all his handlers all his lieutenants no
you could not and they would not let you
get close to him
so that was one i would say in terms of
how he speaks
he is definitely one of these big
picture folks like he'll speak
in big metaphors he'll speak in kind of
the arc of history
um as someone who studied history i
could appreciate that
but um some people love that
he can just sort of fit together a
future you know
the technological future of the next 30
years into
a um coherent narrative and that just
really resonates and then everything he
does is kind of fitting
the narrative for other people that is
just inflexible and like impossible to
actually do anything with like he could
say
ai is going to have a bigger impact on
the world than
the you know microchip and you can be
like cool that may be right like what
does that actually mean for us
in the day-to-day you know and and one
of the big things that i was trying to
understand was like okay
if he thinks that data and ai are the
future
um what does that actually mean for
these companies like can uber actually
benefit from that
in any meaningful way can doordash
suddenly
beat all its competitors just because we
understand that data is important like
there are limits to what you can do with
data
and in fact like people are much more
mindful now about how their data is used
so i think for me the interesting thing
was that he has this like 40 000 foot
view of the worlds
and and then he's trying to apply it you
know on a company by company basis and i
think that's where things can either go
great or they can go really badly yeah
was there any sense of
um maybe you talked about like him as a
person but any of the views that he held
where
uh you felt like he is either really
misunderstood or people just have
misconceptions like
he believes a but everyone thinks he
believes b
yeah i would say that he um
he sees um the power law
of investing i think just a little more
nakedly than a lot of vcs
um who who actually probably believe it
more in private than they would say
masa just believes that a lot of markets
are a winner take all market
effectively that one brand is just gonna
end up
crushing most of the others and
obviously that's
true in some industries it's not maybe
not so true in other industries
but i think that directionally he's not
as crazy as it seems
about that and so are you know are you
really overpaying in the short term
if all you're doing is trying to find
that outlier like winner take all market
i would say probably not as much as he's
sort of ridiculed for
i think the problem is where you think
that maybe a market is winner take all
and it's not
and so you put a lot of money into
something
without it ever really being able to be
the breakout you know like like
hopefully there will continue to be a
lot of podcast companies and so if you
would just
crazy valued you know gimlet or wonder
or whatever like it will crush every
other podcast company
probably not going to be the case um the
other thing i would say is that i think
like
masa is more self-aware but i think a
lot of people think like he's mindfu
he knows the criticism he's not like
some uh like
i don't know naive person who just like
doesn't understand
what people think about him i just don't
think he cares
and there is something to admire there
of just the person who like
knows that a lot of people doubt them
and just
sleeps well at night anyway like he was
like i was you know i asked him like
what do you think about everyone just
kind of like you know
making fun of the vision fund or
thinking like you're a crazy person for
what you're doing
and he was like oh i had it worse after
the dot-com bubble
he's like this is nothing i don't know
like if if
if i would feel that way but i did kind
of have to respect him for just being so
unperturbed
yeah well and and i think the part that
was interesting is
a lot of people forget he was uh nobody
he became the richest guy in the world
lost it all and i think he became the
richest guy in the world a second time
or came close to it
right and so he's kind of had this uh
this very epic
uh boom and bust cycles personally right
and so i think that that does probably
harden you a little bit
i think it also like you know i think
it's weird for some investors
to have an investor who doesn't seem to
be motivated just by like
hoarding money you know like like i
don't know if it's a gambler mentality
or what it is but like he
as you said he um claims to have been
the richest person in the world briefly
during the dot-com bubble
everything was so crazy that that's very
hard to to
perfectly confirm um but yeah this he
lost softbank lost 90 over 90
almost 99 of its stock value in the
dot-com bubble burst
and he could have easily just like moved
on to something else but he just built
it all up again
and then the question is like why like
if you're already the richest person in
the world
what is compelling and he's not bill
gates going to you know cure malaria or
something
he just like can't stop trying to play
out his thesis
about like where tech is going and i
think that is really confusing for a lot
of investors who whatever they say
are ultimately like money driven yeah
it's uh it's absolutely fascinating
um one other company that you've written
about that uh i think because it's in
the enterprise
uh space people just don't know it as
well as snowflake but obviously now
uh they're going to uh to go public here
and and have kind of this big splash
uh what was your history kind of uh
meeting the company and then writing
that story
yeah so snowflake um is a database
company
um you know i i like to think of it as
sort of like um
improving off of the old oracle data
lakes of of you know 20 30 years ago
um a company that i got to know on the
enterprise software beat
and through my cloud 100 sort of beat
and i thought it was interesting that
they
um basically were like these french
database engineer nerdy guys who um
built a tool that actually like could be
sold pretty well and then brought in a
series of a couple
aggressive sales people to basically run
the company
that doesn't always go super well but um
with bob muglia and then frank slootman
they've had these like elite people
basically
brought in as mercenaries to like sell
their tool to the world
and yet at least one of the co-founders
is still
very involved on the deeply technical
side of snowflake
so that was kind of interesting to me
but again i think one of the most
interesting
things about this company is that
it wasn't really known to anyone until
it hit the market and then people see
its numbers
and suddenly you know everyone's
everyone's like
anticipating this ipo or thinking about
how they're going to play the stock and
all that and it's kind of like funny to
me
because um i get to watch these
companies whether it's datadog or
snowflake
kind of go from boring can't get anyone
to care about them
to like should i buy this stock like
what do i do you know it's like
there there was a lot in between right
um but i do think that
uh snowflake um
you know deserves the attention it's
getting um i'm excited to talk to frank
slootman again
when they're not in quiet period and i'm
allowed to um
i think it's it is a huge company um and
the other thing that's interesting about
them is that they've kind of
perfectly drafted off of the cloud wars
between microsoft google and amazon
so they will be the biggest independent
company
in the cloud you know that is sort of
deep in cloud infrastructure but not
one of those big players absolutely it's
uh
it's fascinating to see just you know a
company pop up out of nowhere and be
worth billions of dollars right people
like wait what is that company
right but you're like look there's lots
and lots of them um i actually saw
uh patrick o'shaughnessy uh tweeted uh
the other day or
recently he said um you know who's
somebody that is a
founder ceo that uh you'd love to hear
from
right and is basically running a
business that you've never known about
before
so i saw somebody tweeted and i forget
the gentleman's name
uh but basically he ended up taking the
company public in the early 2010s
and he owns the memphis grizzlies right
and you're like like this guy's like not
trying to hide right i mean he literally
was an mba team
but just hadn't heard of him before
right and so you're just like that is
pretty cool to see
somebody who's literally a
multi-billionaire uh is
out there in the technology world but
just because of the type of business
that he runs
you know it's not something that kind of
gets covered every day and i think that
a lot of these companies that's becoming
more and more popular right
yeah i mean i think unless you um are
fascinated with like
the underpinnings of the internet or
you're trying to
trade the stocks it's not always obvious
like why you should care about these
companies
that's always been my challenge but i
also see it as like a fun
intellectual challenge to basically make
these enterprise companies
relevant and relatable so like when i
write about a company like zoom
in 2019 some people care
then when the pandemic happened and i
wrote about their like
um making the tool free for schools that
was my most trafficked article of all
time
um i couldn't have written that without
all that prep work i had done you know
in the years before but it was cool to
like see it finally
finally resonate with people you know
that's
awesome uh one of the last stories i
want to talk to you about is uh chris
sacca uh probably the most legendary
angel investor of all time depending on
how you count uh
definitely did things kind of
differently right in terms of truckee
and all of that i remember reading that
piece when you wrote it
uh and just being like you know i can't
believe somebody got him to talk
essentially you know what what did it
take to get him to talk and then kind of
what do you remember from uh
from doing that piece yeah so um that
was again where like the power of my
list
was helpful i had gotten to know chris
abed through the midas list
um and kind of uh was talking to him a
bit about his holdings
and i think he it was kind of like oh
well you know i'll tell my story someday
i'll probably you know i'll probably
write a book but but then when it became
clear that you know
he wasn't going to write a book anytime
soon i was able to be like okay well you
can still do the book later but why
don't you talk to me
you know now and i think you know part
of that was that he just felt
finally comfortable to uh share some of
his success
um you know his billionaire uh status
you know with his holdings um some
people like elite pixel would never want
to be called a billionaire even if they
may be
but i think chris was just like okay
it's time for me to kind of
bite the bullet and be more public
facing with some of that stuff
um and we developed a trust so just lots
of
lots of conversations talking to his
world
and um you know that was that was a
tough one because
uber was still very much one of the top
stories of the day
and chris was very involved in the early
days at uber
um so i spent a lot of time talking to
you know all the usual suspects from the
early uber history
and um you know no one quite had the
same story
you know everyone remembers things a
little differently i think mike isaac
did a really good job
with super pumped with this book to try
to like
hit a lot of the main notes there but
even there i was you know texting mike
being like you know
oh i heard something a little bit
different back during the soccer story
and it's just like
it was one of those things that even as
it was lived it kind of became silicon
valley
lore um so that made it
a fun challenge like almost like a game
of clue
like what is the full story here and i
think chris would never lie but like he
maybe just remembers things
a little differently um but he was in a
unique place where his friends were the
founders of uber
of twitter where he was like there for
this you know 2008
time frame um moment in silicon valley
that was pretty unique
and i think he and ayden senkot and a
couple other folks mike maples
um were just able to sort of
aggressively
seize that gap in the market of the
early stage investing
um you know where the fir the other
firms had gotten a little too
risk-averse or a little too big
and so these angels kind of were able to
build their brand steve anderson
is another great person and now there
are a million of these people
you know that we talked about clubhouse
like clubhouse is full of these like
solo investors
but chris was definitely one of the
first people where he had just built a
network
that allowed him to um
you know get in early to a couple of
these really iconic companies
the other thing from a business lesson
is that he just really doubled down on
himself
um he bought out some of his investors
to own more of his own funds even when
he didn't have a lot of money you know
and he was maxing out credit cards
obviously i'm not advising people to do
that
but he just like had total faith in
himself
and and was willing to like have an
extremely concentrated
position in himself so why did he become
a billionaire because he didn't just
invest in uber or twitter
but he kept doubling down on those
companies year after year
buying out his own investors because he
was so long
you know the positions he had conviction
and i think that's where he's a good
example
yeah i can't remember if it was your
story or another story i read uh where
he was at
um on vacation or whatever with uh
travis and
uh his father and travis is playing uh
we
uh tennis is that was that your story no
i know
okay but i think it was it might have
might have been a mike isaac special i
can't remember
okay i i just i remember thinking about
like
literally having those people as your
friends
right and you know one friend ends up
building you know a 70 billion dollar
company another friend ends up building
you know a 30 billion dollar company and
all you're basically doing is you're
just investing in your friends in the
beginning
and that's not to downplay the uh kind
of the evaluation and you got to believe
you got to actually have you know high
quality friends that can build this
stuff like
all of that is important but it is a
pretty special
um i think network of people that uh he
was able to capitalize on
um and the other part i think i took
away was just uh how aggressive he was
once he knew something was working
right in terms of buying out the
shareholders you're talking about doing
all of those things
um that just seemed to uh to not have
been
popular uh before he started really
doing it yeah i mean for the audience
the the takeaway that i would say is is
you know the tech world felt a lot
smaller than
where um you know you could have like
these small meetups at south by
southwest
where all these founders were getting to
know each other um you could have you
know travis would have people at his
house
for jam sessions that you know went on
to be founders of other companies and so
there was this like small network
unfortunately like you know most of us
are not in those networks right and so i
would just say
um invest invest in your own network
because
south by southwest everybody knows but
like what is the next one it may be
virtual
it may be in a game it may be in a
telegram group
but i would say like hopefully the next
generation
of chris sackos there are dozens of
these small groups where it's not just
like
one house in san francisco is birthing
all the big companies
and i think that was as much just about
the scale
of the tech ecosystem at the time as it
was that like
chris was better at picking people than
everyone else i mean obviously coming
from google
and knowing entrepreneurs it became
easier for him to meet more
entrepreneurs
but i don't think that the next chris
sacca has to be you know a white dude
who worked at google
you know absolutely uh i finished up
each conversation
uh with the same two questions then
you'll get to ask me one
uh but before we get into that there was
one question that came in through
twitter that was very
important uh natalie wants to know why
natalie is so great
and i figured that you would have an
amazing answer for her
so uh why is natalie so great
yeah so my partner natalie sportelli um
if you
if you follow me on twitter you'll see
we we're talking constantly
she's one of the smartest people i know
on brands
and kind of all things uh brand
marketing in the tech world
um working at a vc firm called lyrhippo
lyrehippo
i love having a partner who is in
sort of in the industry with me i love
that we can sort of talk the same
language and we can bounce ideas off
each other
i think natalie is just so driven that
it can
i joke sometimes that she's my lady
macbeth because she's gonna get me
killed
but but it's she's just passionate about
like
moving forward and making a difference
and it makes me
a better person in my job maybe you have
the same thing you know with your
partner
but i say that's what i love about
natalie is that she's probably
eavesdropping right now
she's going to give me feedback when
this comes out she's going to tweet
about it
like and having someone like that in
your corner for good and bad is just
awesome
that's a fantastic answer you you made
no mistakes great
job uh the two questions i ask everybody
else
is uh first what is the most important
book that you've ever read
whoa um i should have probably prepared
that one
i would say um there are fiction books
that have really resonated with me more
than non-fiction books
okay um shadow of the wind and a
gentleman in moscow
are two that come to mind a perfect spy
by john le correa
is one that i own the first edition of
because it's had a huge impact on me
i find that fiction can sort of allow me
to see things differently
and have perspective that i really need
especially when i'm spending so much of
my day reading
other news articles or sort of so deep
in the tech
news world um so while there are
business books that i think are valuable
i would really recommend to the audience
like find a novel
that just changes how you think about
the worlds and that will unlock things
that you don't expect perhaps more than
like you know a book that's like 20 tips
that are going to improve your business
yeah it's a great piece of advice uh the
second question is a little bit more fun
aliens believer or non-believer
man so so i i argue about this with my
friends
um i tend to fall subscribe to the
theory
that there are probably alien
civilizations elsewhere in the universe
but that at least under the current laws
of physics as we know them
they're insurmountably far away and we
just
will not run into them that makes me
kind of sad
in in a lot of ways you know but then i
read something like the theory
of the dark wilderness theory but
actually that's a good thing because a
lot of us would be prey
and there are predators out there and so
it's actually good if people don't know
that
you know humans are around um
i i do think that just it's hard to
believe that we're the only ones out
there
unfortunately i'm not super confident
that will ever
like be we may never find out otherwise
is i guess the way to put it yeah
i think that's a very very fair way to
look at it uh a friend
recently was telling me he said uh you
know humans think that we're great
because we're all human
but uh if you just compare us
athletically to like animals
like we're pretty stupid and unathletic
and like not very impressive
and so you know the odds that uh
there is something else out there that
is uh less superior
to us when there's things on earth that
are more superior
uh is not good and so you know to that
point i think that uh
you know i always think of it in terms
of do we want to find them or do it we
want them to find us and i think you
always want to do the discovery right
you don't want to be the discovered
unless unless they want to help us but i
do think that um
you know as much as i'm i love like
space technology and i love a lot of
like the thought about like
the innovation we can do to kind of both
explore but also perhaps like leave the
planet
i do think that of course encourages
thinking that
leads us to invest less in our own house
and
so i do think like if we ever want that
opportunity we'd have to like do a much
better job of like protecting our own
house
um from a climate standpoint from a lot
of standpoints before we can like
go like high-five with aliens you know
somewhere else
absolutely all right you get one
question to ask me what do you got for
me to finish up
what has been the question
that you asked the most to people
because it
brings the most sort of unexpected or
just like gold
answers to you that it's become your
like favorite question
uh so i'll give you two uh the reason
why i asked the alien question
is because i think it is the fastest way
to get
somebody to explain a lot about them
without saying anything and what i mean
by that is just
it shows you how they think about you
know kind of
problems they don't deal with every day
uh you get to see sense of humor you get
to see seriousness
you get to see scientific versus not you
know you get to see kind of
um like uh religiosity a little bit like
just i believe because i believe type
stuff um so it's just a very uh
revealing question
uh the problem is that uh i've done so
many of them now like i pretty much can
bucket
the answers like it's either like i
believe because there's mathematical
probability or
i don't believe because i haven't seen
them yet like those are the two most
popular answers so
i don't know for me it's like what
people say is less important than how
they say it
with that question so that's always been
one that i enjoy uh but the question
now that um i don't remember where i got
this from this was not like i had some
you know
major aha and i was like i started
asking people that uh but i
really enjoy asking people after they've
told me their perspective on something
like what would change your mind um
right and so like especially when it
comes to like
you know technology investing or
business building and finance and stuff
like that
somebody will lay out like this amazing
argument and like it's pretty compelling
right most people i think are like
fairly charismatic if you're
you don't have some level of success
you're a good salesperson um you've been
able to convince employees and investors
like all this kind of stuff
and then to have them like okay now flip
around on the other side of the table
and tell me like what basically what's
your critics argument
and like what would have to happen for
you to like agree with them and what it
does is it like
one the smartest people that i've done
on the podcast like by far they can say
their critics argument better than the
credit can
right and like are very clear and like
you know a b and c happens and i would
change my mind
and you're like okay like that's
actually pretty cool that you can do
that
uh then there's people who uh are like
so convicted that nothing's gonna change
their mind and like they say that
and so like i don't i haven't decided
yet is that like a good thing or a bad
thing because it
it's kind of situation dependent like
sometimes you need the blind faith
that something is going to occur whether
you can explain it or not
and then other times like i don't know
maybe you get we work
right like you know like you basically
like run off the cliff
blindly it's funny you say that because
masa would definitely be
in the latter camp where you probably
aren't gonna change his mind but dustin
moskowitz
um actually is known and with for
employees for asking how can the
opposite be true
or okay how could the exact opposite of
the story you just told me
be true and he actually does play the
same kind of empathy
exercise yeah i i see the same
um sides of that coin all the time in my
reporting as well
yeah that's awesome and i don't think
either one's like right or wrong
right because obviously both of those
two people are highly successful it's
just a matter of um
to me as i look at this as like a
learning exercise
it's the fastest way to get the counter
narrative
uh and you can pretty much tell you know
like hey is this person bullshitting or
not right and do they actually
understand the critics argument
um but the people who i think are the
most intelligent they
really really can outline like you know
here's what it would take for me to
change my mind i just
enjoy that can i can i sneak one more
question
of course um you you've talked to a ton
of people now
do you ever have a moment where you feel
like you just really misread a person
or how how good would you rate your own
ability to kind of quickly get the
measure of someone just from your
pattern recognition
so it's one of these things where uh i
think we all
want to believe that we're really good
at that type of stuff but like we all
probably actually suck
at it or we're like worse at it than we
than we actually uh are
or we believe we are um i think that uh
you can cut a person in many different
ways right so like in one conversation
it's really hard to get uh a lot of
reads
in terms of like all these different
things but like being able to make a
read like that person is intelligent and
uh has sound decision making from one
conversation like you can ask enough
questions where at least directionally
you're probably more right than wrong
right so like that's something that that
i think you can get out of one
conversation
the other thing is um i think of it as
like salesmanship
and what i mean by that is especially
for our founders like everyone wants to
know like who's the smartest
and being smart is really important but
also being able to convince employees
convince investors convince the market
like all of that is really important as
well and i think that naturally
when you just have a conversation with
somebody you walk away and you're like
oh that person is charismatic or that
person is not
um so i think you can read that pretty
effectively the things that are hard are
just like
how persistent is this person and they
can tell you stories about their past
where they were persistent or not and
like maybe that gives you some signal
but you know for us like when early
stage investing
most of the companies that have failed
like at some point the founders gave up
and maybe there was good reason to or
maybe there wasn't but
i i think like that's the stuff that you
know kind of what somebody's made of
right it's kind of the cliche way of
describing it just how do you get that
out of a single conversation i think
you got to spend a lot of time with
somebody to really unpack that
um and so you know if i had one wish it
would be
to be able to get that type of
information out of a single conversation
but i think it's just
you know human nature makes it too
difficult awesome
thanks thanks for that that's i'd say
there's some
there's a lot of important things to
keep in mind there that i think
reporters
um we do the same thing where we can
overread
but of course people are putting their
best foot forward with us and so
you know trying to understand if you
really have the measure of a person we
end up having to
sort of try to triangulate it you know
if you're talking to other people too
i'm assuming nobody on a list or that
you're doing a profile on is like hey
let me introduce you to
all of these companies that didn't work
that i was involved with
no we usually have to do that work
ourselves
absolutely all right alex listen thank
you so much for doing this where uh
where can people find you on the
internet
uh or find more of uh of the stories
that you're writing
yeah so um my twitter handle is alex r
conrad with a k um i'm always on twitter
if you tweet at me
i'll probably be responding um and then
if you
go to forbes if you just google my name
you'll find my forbes author page which
has all these stories
um ditto the cloud 100 we have pretty
good seo
so um find me there but if you want to
talk to me
um twitter is probably the best place to
be awesome listen thank you so much for
doing this and watch it again in the
future
all right thanks man really appreciate
it